fourth session of the mathematics online
learning workshop
i am uh happy to introduce naman
argherwal
who is from google a princeton in a lot
of designs lab and he's done lots of
good work on online lqr
and online control and i'm really
interested in hearing your talk so uh
please take it away
thanks alan thanks for the introduction
thanks for inviting me
uh let me just share screen
uh can this be seen
yep i can see it okay sounds good okay
uh thanks for coming to the talk uh my
name is naman
uh i plan to talk about uh this
framework which we
have been sort of thinking about at our
lab uh for
a couple of years now uh we call this
the non-stochastic control framework
um the work that i'm going to present
today is
a year a year and a half older uh but
hopefully that's kind of uh
the work that sets up the other stuff so
hopefully i hope you can make some
intuitions and i'll make pointers to
other work which might be interesting to
folks
afterwards okay so uh let me begin by
just uh thanking my collaborators uh
this work was
joint work with brian ballins
visiting us then and currency
okay so what is this about uh well it's
about controlling dynamical systems
um and sort of it finds this topic is
age old and sort of finds applications
new and old
ups maybe newer applications include
things like autonomous vehicles
uh in google there are things like data
center cooling
uh which i found uh which of uh like
where controller dynamical systems have
found
applications uh and sort of something
that our labs have been working on uh
should be released pretty soon it's
controlling things like medical
ventilation
in the present scenario okay so what's a
dynamical system well
here's a cartoon basically it's anything
that you can essentially actuate
and you can control to sort of have a
certain behavior that you
wanted to have okay so uh
of course control theory is a as an
age-old field um
what's sort of the motivation for our
work we sort of uh i guess
our work stems from sort of like trying
to think of control in the age of say
machine learning
um the sort of focus that we want to
have uh with this work is kind of
focus on sort of the notions of
robustness which we consider in machine
learning
uh and sort of bring in the notion of
simple algorithms like gradient descent
which have found to be
sort of more more robust and sort of
efficient in this large data regime
uh moving forward one would sort of try
and imagine things like non-linear
controllers based on deep neural
networks and things like that
so these sort of form uh so getting this
sort of
more machine learning focused robustness
notion
was the motivation for our work uh
so sort of without dealing it further
let me just begin uh the first part i'm
going to talk about this work uh
which appeared in icml uh should be uh
19
uh online control with adversarial
perturbations
let me just set that work up directly so
before before setting the workup
let me define the notion of say optimal
control of dynamical systems
uh a dynamical system is essentially
governed by like a state equation and
the state equation has multiple parts
there exists a state of the dynamical
systems which is donated by
denoted by this uh variable x sub t
there is a control input that you
provide to
the dynamical system at every time
that's denoted by use of t
and there is uh there is a certain
perturbation that drives the system
okay so given x u and wt
so the state kind of advances ahead with
some known equation
be given by some function f and sort of
the goal in optimal control
is given a certain cost function you
want to sort of a cost function on
the state and the control you want to
come up with a strategy
of control or a sequence of controls to
minimize this
uh this uh this this cost over time
okay so i'm going to consider throughout
the stock i'm just going to look at
discrete time systems
uh and in particular the the precise
dynamical system that i will be looking
at uh will be
uh a sub case but a rich sort of sub
case
uh of the general case of dynamical
systems is called the linear dynamical
system a linear dynamical system
basically
uh the next the next state transition is
a linear function
of your uh of your state and of your
control
okay so that's the setup that's the
problem
that i want to look at and sort of let
me begin by sort of saying
some sort of sort of a very high level
overview of sort of what's been
done before of course this topic has
been uh studied
since uh the 60s since the name of
kalman um
sort of uh the most canonical result in
this field
is uh is a controller called the linear
quadratic regulator
and here in sort of the the assumption
is that the perturbations that you get
at every time
point is are let's say uh drawn from an
independent gaussian noise
independent across time and acro
independent of everything before
and the costs are quadratic so the
quadratic functions of the state
and the control input in such a setting
it's well known that the solution
depends
so the solution the optimal control law
is a linear function of the state so u t
is equal to k times x t where k is a
matrix that you can compute
uh which depends upon the system itself
so it depends on a comma b
okay so just to sort of give an idea of
why this happens uh
sort of the intuition is quite simple
it's about just writing the bellman
optimality equations so if you sort of
uh
what you begin with the sort of assuming
that the value function at any time t so
from any time t
forward uh if you're at a state the
optimal value function
looks like a quadratic uh in the state
that you're in
and sort of if you expand this out uh
one more level to solve the
bellman optimality equation the value of
the value equation
basically you continue getting your sort
of uh
inductive assumption that um the value
function is quadratic
and you also sort of easily get that the
control uh input is linear in x
okay so that's sort of
a linear quadratic regulator and
one of the main assumptions that goes
into the linear quadratic regulator that
we sort of want to challenge in the work
is the assumption of independent
gaussian noise
and quadratic cost so these are sort of
central assumptions to get things like
uh so to get sort of uh this this result
about linear quadratic regulators
and sort of just looking at the aspect
of uh
removing uh sort of the independence
assumption over
noise i think people have looked at this
before
and a notion that is very popular uh
sort of in this field
is called h infinity control or sort of
you can think of it as a min
max version of the control so i want to
be able to
sort of say something in a worst case
sense about
wt so what you do is to bring is to set
up
a min max problem so here you're sort of
trying to find
the best sequence of
control inputs such that
against any uh sort of such that against
the worst
uh w1 to t say an adversary might decide
of say of bounded norm that this overall
cost is minimized
okay so i didn't say this before i'm
going to assume that
uh sort of uh the initial state is zero
and then sort of the whole system is
just driven by the control inputs that
you provide
and the perturbations that are provided
through some process or through some
adversary
and in h infinity control you are trying
to sort of guard against the worst
possible adversary
with respect to a single sort of uh
input sequence
okay so sort of looking at
the control a little bit it's kind of
easy to see that like
while the notion is extremely strong its
strength sort of makes it
extremely pessimistic so in some sense
what you're doing is you're sort of
trying to guard against every possible
bad sequence an adversary
uh might provide and in that sense it is
fairly uh sort of pessimistic
uh the second thing that kind of happens
while this is sort of easy that while
solutions for this problem exist when
uh the cost functions are quadratics
sort of when you want to
go beyond quadratic cost functions uh to
say
general convex functions which might
come about because you might have some
constraints and things like that
um this this problem tends to be
computationally ill behaved
it's not clear whether it's easily
attractively solvable
um so there are two sort of problems
with h infinity control
it's pessimistic sort of non-adaptive
and computationally ill behaved and
these are the sort of things that we
want to
sort of target uh in via this sort of
framework of non-stochastic control
uh so what we want to add to this story
is uh
to sort of add ideas from online
learning get some notion of
regret or a regret analysis something
which is more of an adaptive performance
metric
and something that sort of yields
efficient methods for
directly for something like general
losses something that's not specific to
quadratic losses
something that leads to efficient
methods for general convex losses
as well
okay uh so sort of just to give you a
motivating example of why one might want
to study something like this so imagine
you want to
uh fly a drone from some source to
destination
you understand your drone completely but
sort of there is uh there are unknown
factors in the environment there might
be wind rain
other uncertainties which are clearly
sort of non-stochastic right you should
not expect wind to be stochastic any
uh in any way um and sort of what
are like optimal control robust control
theory or each infinity control says
is to plan sort of in a worst case sense
over all possible win conditions okay so
uh this is clearly overtly pessimistic
what if when you sort of try uh when you
go on to fly your drone what if there
was no wind or what if wind was of a
very
very particular structure that you could
have sort of taken advantage of
okay so our goal here is to sort of get
some notion of adaptive control
which sort of gives us the best of both
worlds if we wanted to sort of be
optimal and fast when the weather
permits
and sort of be also optimal to sort of
instance
perturbations but also it should not
sort of go
extremely bad when uh sort of you hit
that sort of worst case
which uh each infinity control uh
guarantees against okay so we want to
get finite improvable guarantees
um and for this we will sort of
introduce this online game
which i'm going to define next and
define an appropriate notion of regret
which we will which we which which will
sort of capture
uh some part of h infinity control and
which will also be hopefully
more adaptive
okay so let me just sort of set up uh
the problem
uh so just to define it again uh so this
is what we call the non-stochastic
control problem
you've given a linear dynamical system
that evolves according to this following
equation
and you want to mean you want to sort of
come up with a sequence of controls
so as to minimize this cumulative cost
there should be a summation there
that's a small typo and sort of the
salient aspects of
the problem of of the setup that we want
to care about
is that we want these costs to be convex
general convex functions
and we want to make no assumption about
sort of
the way the perturbations or the noise
is being
generated so in particular it could be
generated by an adversary
and such things okay
so um just before i move on let me just
make some clarifications about the kind
of thing which we are going to assume
uh i'm going to assume for the rest of
this talk that um
the system is fully known so i know the
matrices
a and b i'm also going to assume
that the system is fully observed so i'm
going to assume that you can have
complete observation about the state x
sub t and i'm also of course going to
assume that the system is time invariant
so this system does not change with
respect to time there's no e t
comma b t it's just a and b
given these assumptions uh let me just
make a small point
if i've assumed that the system is known
and
the the state is fully known
you're the one who is deciding uh sort
of the control input
so i can without loss of generality
assume that the perturbations
are fully observable as well okay so
by at from this point on i'm going to
assume that the perturbations w sub t
are also fully observed okay
so let me set up the online control
sort of the this online control of lds
or the non-stochastic control framework
that
i've been talking about so let me set up
this in terms of an online game
so imagine there are two players in this
game
there is a blue player and there's a red
player and there is
a dynamical system that's that's given
by the state
x sub t at every round t
the blue player plays a control say u
sub t
and what the red player does is that it
reveals a cost function
so it's an online game so it reveals a
cost function that has two arguments the
state of the system and the control
input that the blue player is providing
okay so that's what happened happens at
every round t
and after the two players have committed
to sort of
their particular strategies
what happens is that the system evolves
so the system evolves via
the known system equation x of p plus 1
is equal to a times x of t
b plus b times u sub t plus w sub t
and the blue player suffers the cost uh
produced by the red player so the blue
player suffers a cost
of c sub t uh acting on x of t
and u sub t okay so that's the game
that's and this goes on for t rounds as
is typical in
online games um and sort of
what we want to do in this setting is to
attack a notion of policy regret so let
me just define what
the notion of policy regret is i mean we
are not defining this this has been
defined before
uh what you're basically doing is you
want to minimize your own
cost so you want to minimize the sum of
c sub t of x of t and u t
and as a benchmark you want to compare
yourself or your solution or your cost
uh against some policy so some policy
within a policy class okay so
capital pi some policy class let's say
and i want to compare sort of how well
my controls uh have done uh sort of with
respect to some
with respect to some policy insider
policy class
what's here on the right hand side let
me just
make something clear what you have is a
counter factual notion of regret
so what you're trying to compare against
is
in hindsight having observed all the
sort of like
uh w sub ts in some sense what uh what
is the best policy inside the policy
class
and then sort of execute that policy
under the same state evolution
that you sort of uh went through so
the it generates a new sequence of
states it cannot be the same sequence of
states because a different
policy is being executed and sort of you
want to compare against
this kind of a policy regret metric
okay so this is what sort of
differentiates it from say standard
online
learning where this contractual notion
changes the sort of
state that you're visiting when you're
sort of comparing yourself
uh to the optimal okay sorry i have one
quick
question so the wt's here are shared
between the comparator
and the learner yes yes yes so that's
the
that's an assumption that we make on the
system uh
the wt's are indeed shared between so
uh your uh your cost as well as your
comparator
so since this was brought up let me just
uh sort of say what we want to do
uh i didn't sort of define what we want
to do with w sub ts i didn't see how
they were generated
so basically we want to bound this
regret
uh notion with respect to all possible
uh w1 to wt okay so the only assumption
that we're going to make on the ws
is that at each step it is bounded say
by one but of course this could be any
number
so we're going to assume that at each
step w sub t is bounded but otherwise
it's a totally arbitrary sequence
and indeed it's the same wt that's being
used in sort of
the cost that you're suffering in the
comparator that you're considering
okay um so as i said sort of let me just
remind uh the setup
uh these costs are assumed to be convex
uh
we are assuming the system to be a known
time invariant
system and sort of you're assuming full
observation
so i'm just going to take a few more
seconds to leave this up there in case
people have questions about the setup
well so are you restricting the policy
class
yes so i'm gonna do that so i i mean
this is a very general setup that i did
i haven't yet spoken about
the policy class that i'm going to be uh
working with
okay so this is in general like a game
for any policy class and now i'm going
to play
sort of restrict the policy class that
i'm going to work with
okay so that's that was a good segue to
the next slide
uh what is a reasonable comparative
policy class um
and sort of thinking about this a little
bit um
one kind of uh sort of reasonable policy
class is to compare yourself to
to the class of linear policies uh so
for things like when the noise is
gaussian we know that in sort of the
infinite uh
limit or in in sd goes to infinity
and uh sort of the perturbations are
drawn in from a gaussian distribution
the optimal thing to do is basically
display
a linear policy so that's a reasonable
policy class
um this is sort of where we started off
our work with
we wanted to capture linear policies and
sort of what we do is
a slightly more general version of this
i'm just going to describe that
now uh sort of more a slightly more
general notion of
a linear policy is to have a notion of
uh linear dynamical controllers so
herein you can sort of assume that
uh like your controller itself holds
some state and sort of like you know
uh it by itself in in internally is a
linear dynamical
system this is sort of not that relevant
for maybe this talk but
this kind of thing turns out to be
optimal when you sort of have partial
observation
and the precise policy class that we are
going to work with
is a generalization of the above two uh
this is uh this is known as disturbance
feedback controller so let me describe
this
a little bit more carefully um so this
policy class
essentially uses as uh sort of uh
as input the disturbances or the
perturbations that you've seen in the
past
so suppose you're making a decision at
time t
you sort of look at all the disturbances
that have existed from w1 to wt minus
one
and what you do is you parametrize your
policy by
individual linear functions on these
disturbances okay so your policy is
given parameterized by matrices
m1 m2 all the way back uh and the action
that you're going to place is going to
be a sum
of uh the of this matrix
multiplied with this so it's a linear
function of
uh it's a linear function of these uh
of these disturbances okay so
let me just be a little bit more clear i
mean this is just a linear function
we can also handle affine functions and
in fact all results hold for affine
functions
but just to be clear in this talk i'm
just going to leave it linear
okay we actually have a question from
the chat if you wouldn't mind
sure yeah please a quick interruption um
miriam asks
or points out that when your policies
with a fixed k or optimal for
infinite horizon lqrs
horizon yes yes yes i i mentioned that
as t goes to infinity
that's only when these are optimal i
should have mentioned it before when i
said the optimal thing for finite
horizon indeed that
it's it's not true that they're actually
they're the optimal one
so is there any way to motivate the
fixed k assumption
um i guess the the sort of easiest way
to motivate the fixed k assumption
i mean you could sort of like if indeed
sort of you're like
this is a fixed system so if your game
is sort of uh
it's going to be a long term game in
some sense it should start to approach
like a fixed game
saying um i guess i mean okay so
sort of the easiest motivation i i guess
i have for
this thing is that uh sort of any way we
sort of work with a more general policy
class than
uh a fixed k um and
i guess i mean okay so we are shooting
for a very strong notion of potentially
uh sort of um having sub-linear
uh regret and like you like this
this seems like for instance like this
is the first step towards sort of
making something like that happen and
something like
and that sort of a very natural class in
that sense is
uh the linear policy class um
this kind of thing as i said like it
leads to a generalization
any way of doing linear dynamical
controllers uh
indeed it might not be optimal for uh
for like for any sequence of uh noise it
might not even be potentially the
optimal
uh i guess the way to think about it is
like you know
like let's sort of treat this as a
comparator and derive a potential
algorithm
and sort of that's our hope in some
sense um
yeah i guess that's uh that's sort of uh
the best motivation i have and of course
st if you have sort of t going to
infinity then it kind of captures
sort of what the default thing to do is
right one thing i hope that linear
policies are uh
would be performant in that case this
sort of notion of program is comparative
exactly exactly exactly exactly
okay okay so moving on so let me just
quickly
show why sort of this notion of
disturbance feedback control is more
general than leaning controls uh
this is kind of not very hard to say uh
the way this
the the way this comes out is if you
just look at uh sort of
um the law sort of that governs the
control action
and if you just open it up uh
recursively with respect to each time
what you see is sort of everything kind
of just opens up because everything
depends on
uh like everything is interdependent and
the only thing that sort of just remains
is indeed um just uh
uh the perturbations and sort of
like if you just open it up you get an
expression that just looks like this
indeed the sort of controls that you're
playing at any point of time
they're not a linear function of the k
but they indeed turn out to be linear
functions of the perturbations
okay so if you sort of just relax this k
times summation a plus b k to the i uh
matrix into one of the mis it is easy to
see that the control that you are
basically just playing
is captured by this class of controls
okay this class of disturbance feedback
controls
okay so let me just state uh let me just
go ahead and state the result
um our main result is that we provide an
efficient algorithm
such that for any sequence w one to t
the regret notion that i had defined
before with respect to the policy class
of disturbance feedback controllers
is bounded by uh order of square root t
okay so let me just say what i mean
when i say things are efficient um the
algorithm is going to remain polynomial
in system parameters uh it's going to
remain logarithmic in time
uh in with respect to its sort of uh
implementation
and something which i'm going to clarify
in a little bit
uh we also need certain amount of
stability notion
from our system and i'm going to define
it precisely what we need
but as long as that is satisfied which
is something which is not extremely
strong it's something
mild and something like something like
this should probably hold like
you should have that to have something
uh sort of to get something like this in
an offspring
regret for in something which is uh
truly uh online and adversarial right so
the costs are also at the cereal
adversarially chosen uh so that's the
result uh that is
uh the regret bound uh i'm hoping to
sort of show or at least convey all the
ideas uh behind sort of how we get this
regret bound
um
just like you know you have about five
minutes left oh that's it
that was a happy duck but there'll be um
plenty of time for discussions
afterwards
okay sounds good so let me just quickly
go ahead um
uh so essentially um oh sorry i didn't
have a clock in front of me so i should
have
okay anyway um so let me just convey
sort of the main ingredients of
uh the result uh so the main the first
ingredient to sort of convexification
um here the problem by nature
uh becomes non-convex if you
parameterize it
in k okay so like if i
like we said if we look at the equation
of how the action looks like with
respect to k
this is clearly a non-convex function of
k and this relaxation that we did to
sort of disturbance feedback control
this makes the problem sort of very like
the
the as a function of m my control is
just a
clearly a linear function and sort of if
you roll this
this idea out what you get is the state
that you're going to reach
if you're going to play the sort of the
same uh policy which is given by this m
over time that also looks like a linear
function of
m so this overall thing as a function of
m looks convex
so essentially what we've done is that
sort of the the hard problem the
of sort of even just the non-convex
problem of the offline optimal
uh which looked immediately non-convex
we've sort of converted into a convex
problem
and um so what we can do now sort of
just change our game to be
with respect to these m matrices so uh
the blue player basically just plays
m matrices at sort of t matrices at
every point of time
and the action is chosen by this sort of
policy
and again sort of we can now define a
policy regret which is in the same
fashion
which is this kind of actual notion but
sort of there are two
immediate hurdles that you come into now
i sort of need to have
potentially too many parameters because
my time goes back all the way uh
till sort of uh until till the start of
time so i need potentially team any
parameters
and the second notion the second thing
is that it's still not reduced to say
something like an online convex
optimization problem because
it the counter factual notion still
exists so the state that
uh sort of you reach depends upon
everything you've done in the past
so you sort of have this kind of actual
notion and we will sort of deal in the
next
sort of things with both of these uh
issues
um so to get sort of rid of the sort of
the number of parameters in the system
um
we're going to assume that there exists
some so this is the stability assumption
that we're going to make in the system
this is called strongly stable
systems what i'm going to assume is that
there exists some linear policy
such that a minus b k has a spectral
radius of less than 1 minus delta where
delta is a small constant
um sorry and
uh as long as i'm given access to any
stabilizing linear policy
uh what we can show is basically that if
you look at an action that looks like k
times x t plus sort of something that
has a finite horizon
of sort of uh past perturbation so if
you only hit it with the linear function
of past
h perturbations as long as h scales are
something like log t
and you've got this stability thing h
will of course be inversely proportional
to delta
this can sort of emulate any stable
linear policy
and as long as this k is a stabilizing
matrix you can also show that any
disturbance policy is stable
so what do i mean by stable in some
sense what it means is that
sort of what you did sort of beyond
eight steps in the past
does not affect okay so it's in some
sense it's a bounded memory system
okay so that's what stability does and
with stability sort of this game that
sort of we needed to predict m1 till mp
reduces to just being able to predict
m1 till mh for h something like log t
so of course we have now reduced the
number of parameters in the system which
is logarithmic in time and potentially
polynomial in the parameters of the
system the only little component
left now which we sort of need to care
about is that xt still depends on past
actions uh and this uh this we sort of
deal with again
using this notion of stability and the
the main idea here is that so the
stability as i said
implies that only past h many actions
matter
nothing before that is going to matter
and sort of to deal with this in some
sense what you can
is we use this reduction uh into a
different
framework called oco with memory which
was introduced by
a nava at all and the idea is the
following
this will take a minute and that's
probably the last minute i'm going to
spend
essentially what you're going to do is
that the cost at any point of time
which depends on the state and the
control
since everything about the system due to
the stability nature
only depends on what you've done in the
past eight steps
sort of the cost that you're paying at
this point of time is
just some function which remains convex
in this case
of the past h decisions that you've made
and remember each of these decisions
are of the type playing something from a
disturbance
feedback policy so it only depends on
the past eight
things that you've played and this was
exactly the kind of
uh setup that was considered in this oco
with
memory framework wherein you're playing
a game similar to like in
a standard uco game but the cost
function that the adversary provides
depends
not only on your present action but
rather a finite window of size
h of your actions in the past and what
you compare yourself again is with
respect to something that's a static
sort of policy static decision from your
decision set
okay so in this case you skin sort of
show that like
if you've got a setup like this uh all
you need to do
is an algorithm that resembles basically
gradient descent
what you do is at any time at any point
of time you sort of
play a gradient step on this proxy cost
function
okay so you sort of take all of its
components set it to the same value
xxx let's say and then you just take a
gradient with respect to x and that's
what that's what you
sort of propagate your gradient descent
algorithm with
and essentially the idea is that sort of
this sort of exploits the slow moving
meter of ogd
and lipschitzness so to sort of get this
uh of square root t
bound so that's uh so this is kind of um
the the algorithm basically you're just
creating these
uh sort of cost functions which are sort
of the cost
that you will suffer right now uh sort
of based on what the
what each actions that you've sort of
proposed this proxy cost function
essentially just does
imagine you went eight steps behind you
sort of played the same policy for eight
steps
look at the cost that you're sort of
suffering at this point of time
take a gradient with respect to that
cost and then just move on
okay so that's it so that's what uh sort
of gives you
this result um i guess i'm
out of time is it yeah if we don't mind
maybe we should take questions at the
end
but uh thank you that was really
interesting i've been meaning to look
into the supply network more recently
okay let me just stop i prefer
uh let me just quickly say something um
i guess i can say this in the discussion
as well
um there is code available uh please do
this controller we sort of put it up as
part of this at this link so feel free
to sort of play around with it
great thank you